Using an algorithm though,
do you not miss context?
I mean it seems to me that there's a
lot of people that say things in humor,
you know, or, or slurs within
particular communities,
which is perfectly
reasonable, right? So yes,
there is a danger of the algorithm
is missing context and that's why we,
we really want to go carefully into this
and this is why we've scoped it down
first and foremost to doxing,
which is at least first it hits her
number one goal of protecting physical
safety.
Like making sure that nothing done online
will impact someone's physical safety
on offline,
on our platform in this case.
The second is that there are patterns
around doxing that are much easier to see
without having the context. There
are, there are exceptions of course,
cause you could docs, um, someone's
public, you know, uh, uh, representatives,
public, uh, office, phone
number and email address.
And the algorithm might catch that,
not have the context that this is a US
representative and this information is
already public.
So essentially this just,
it highlights how insanely difficult
it is to monitor all of these posts.
And then what, what is the volume?
Like what, what are we dealing with?
Like how many posts do you guys get a day?
Hundreds of millions of posts a day.
And how many human beings are manually
reviewing any of these things?
I don't have that, that number. A
lot. Thousands. Hundreds of thousands.
How many employees? You guys have 4,000
employees around the world. That's it.
We have 4,000 employees.
The reason that's crazy though,
but stop and think about that.
4,000 people that are monitoring hundreds
of millions of tweets. And uh, we,
we have, uh, we have, uh,
we have a small team who's
monitoring tweets and some
of them are employed by us.
Some of them are contractors throughout,
throughout the world. So 4,000 employees,
total, 4,000 employees who are
engineers, who are designers,
who are lawyers so that people actually
monitoring tweets is probably less than
a thousand.
Uh,
well the reason we don't give out
specific numbers is we need to scale these
dynamically, right? If we see a particular
event within, uh, within country,
we might hire 100 more people
on contract to deal with it,
whereas they may not be full and,
and with us the entire time,
or they have the ability to take down
tweets. Uh, they have, they have the,
so as we get reports, it goes into a
queue and those are ranked by severity.
And then we have people who look
at our rules and look at the,
look at the tweets and look at the
behavior and the context around it.
And they have the ability to go
down that enforcement spectrum.
The vigil talked about one,
make people log in,
read why it's a violation over tweet
and delete it to temporary suspensions.
And finally, a permanent suspension,
which is the absolute last resort,
which we ultimately do not want to do.
We want to make sure that our rules are
also guided towards incentivizing more
healthy conversation and, and
more, more participation. Yeah.